This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Nearly 50 years ago to the day, one of the darker chapters of American history unceremoniously came to a close. Saigon, April 30, 8 o'clock. The last American helicopter on the roof of the American Embassy prepares to lift off the last of the evacuees fleeing before the advancing communist armies. The United States had pulled direct military involvement two years prior, but the Vietnam War officially concluded when Saigon fell to North Vietnamese forces. As that chapter ended, a new one began for nearly two million South Vietnamese refugees
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。就在差不多50年前的今天，美国历史上最为黑暗的篇章之一，在不够光彩的情况下画上了句号。西贡，4月30日，8点整。美国大使馆屋顶上的最后一架美军直升机准备起飞，载着最后一批在逼近的共产主义军队面前逃亡的撤离人员离开。美国在两年前就已经撤出了直接军事介入，但随着西贡落入北越军队之手，越战正式宣告结束。随着那一篇章的落幕，近两百万南越难民迎来了新的一页
who fled to new countries in the decades after. We decided to mark the 50th anniversary of the fall of Saigon by rebroadcasting an episode from the archive about the afterlife of a flag and how its meaning, for better or worse, continues to evolve long after the country it represents no longer exists. Just note, this episode does talk about the January 6th attack on the Capitol. Since this story first aired in 2021, Trump has pardoned every single violent insurrectionist. Nothing factually about the original reporting has changed.
他们在随后的几十年里逃往了新的国家。我们决定重播档案中的一集节目，以此来纪念西贡陷落50周年，探讨一面旗帜的“来世”，以及无论好坏，为什么在它所代表的国家早已不复存在很久之后，其含义仍在不断演变。请注意，本节目确实谈到了1月6日国会山袭击事件。自从这篇报道于2021年首次播出以来，特朗普已经赦免了每一个暴力叛乱分子。最初的报道在事实层面没有任何改变。
We just wanted to say that they were violent insurrectionists, whether they are in prison or not. I'm sorry to do this, but I'm going to take you back to January 6th, 2021. — I can see at least half a dozen protesters scaling, literally climbing. — A violent mob of Trump supporters attempted to overturn the 2020 election results with physical force. They broke into the Capitol, disrupted the Electoral College vote, and occupied the building for hours. — Like most of you, I had my butt clenched that day, watching the insurrection unfold on television. Producer Vivian Le. I also happen to be watching that news coverage with my mom.
我们只想说，无论他们是否身陷囹圄，他们都是暴力的叛乱分子。我很抱歉这么做，但我得带大家回到2021年1月6日。“——我能看到至少六名抗议者在攀爬，字面意义上的攀爬。”——一群暴力的特朗普支持者试图用武力推翻2020年大选结果。他们闯入国会大厦，打断了选举人团的投票，并在大楼里占领了数小时。“——和你们大多数人一样，那天我也提心吊胆，在电视上看着叛乱的展开。”制作人薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）。我也正好和妈妈一起看着那些新闻报道。
I see every channel. I watch it, ABC, I watch CBS, I watch CNN, I watch Fox. Every, every perspective. This is my mom, by the way. Do you want to say hi to my boss real fast? Fenty. Roman. Hi, Roman.
我能看到所有频道。我看ABC、CBS、CNN、还有福克斯（Fox）。每个视角都看。顺便说一下，这是我妈妈。你想跟我老板打个招呼吗？芬蒂（Fenty）。罗曼。嗨，罗曼。
This is Vivian's mom. Hey, mom. So that day during the insurrection, yes, we were both horrified. And yes, we were both worried about the state of democracy. But as my mom and I scanned the aerial shots of the rioters marching down Pennsylvania Avenue, we also couldn't help but notice the dizzying amount of different
这是薇薇安的妈妈。嗨，妈妈。所以在叛乱那天的确，我们俩都吓坏了。是的，我们俩也都很担心民主的现状。但正如我和妈妈扫视着示威者沿宾夕法尼亚大道行进的航拍镜头时，我们也忍不住注意到，那天那里出现了令人头晕目眩的大量不同
types of flags there that day. Aside from seeing the obvious choices like the US or MAGA flag, there were some that were just really hideous graphic designs, like the flag of Trump photoshopped as Rambo, or Calvin from Kelvin and Hobbes peeing on Biden? Stupid. Just seemingly, you know, not attract me. They don't attract me either, Mom. Then there were the flags that, even for a person like me, who spends a lot of time thinking about flags, couldn't decode. Yeah, I don't understand what to stand for, for some flag, you know.
种类的旗帜。除了看到像美国国旗或MAGA旗这样显而易见的选择外，还有一些图形设计简直丑得要命，比如把特朗普P成兰博（Rambo）的旗子，或者《卡尔文和霍布斯》（Calvin and Hobbes）里的卡尔文在拜登身上撒尿？太蠢了。看起来就是那种，你知道的，无法吸引我的旗帜。它们也没法吸引我，妈妈。然后还有一些旗帜，甚至对于像我这样花大量时间思考旗帜的人来说，也无法解读。是的，我不知道有些旗帜代表什么，你知道的。
What is it? Some for brown boy, some for white supremacist? Yeah, supremacy. But I don't know what to stand for because I'm not around here. Ha ha ha. But flying from the balcony of the Capitol building along some of these inscrutable symbols was a flag that my mom instantly recognized.
那是什么？有些代表棕色人种男孩，有些代表白人至上主义？是的，至上主义。但我不知道代表什么，因为我不常接触这些。哈哈哈哈。然而，在国会大厦阳台上飘扬的、与其中一些高深莫测的标志并存的，是一面我妈妈一眼就能认出来的旗帜。
Actually, she more than just recognized it. Ah, that one. That's the one that we love, we cherish all my life. It was such a simple design that most people probably didn't even notice it. Bright yellow with three red horizontal stripes across the center. This was the flag of South Vietnam. This is the flag that she grew up with. It reminds her of some of the best years of her life.
事实上，她不仅仅是认出来了。啊，那个。那是我们深爱、一辈子都珍视的旗帜。它的设计非常简单，大多数人可能甚至都没有注意到它。底色鲜艳，中间有三道平行的红色条纹。这就是南越国旗。这就是她伴随着长大的旗帜。它让她想起她一生中最美好的岁月。
So, when she saw it flying alongside banners that overtly signaled hate, racism, and misogyny that day, it felt like it was telling the rest of the world that, hey, this flag stands for all those things too. I feel ashamed because the people raised it at the wrong day, the wrong event. The flag of South Vietnam and what it should stand for is a really contentious issue for the Vietnamese-American community. And while seeing it raised at the insurrection felt like the wrong way to use this flag for my mom,
所以，当她看到这面旗帜与那天那些公开释放仇恨、种族主义和厌女情绪的横幅一起飘扬时，感觉就像是在向全世界宣告：嘿，这面旗帜也代表所有这些东西。我感到羞耻，因为人们在错误的日子、错误的活动中升起了它。南越国旗以及它应该代表什么，对于美籍越南人社群来说是一个极具争议的问题。虽然在叛乱中看到它升起让我妈妈觉得是这面旗帜的错误用法，
the right way to use it was hard for her to put into words. How is it supposed to be used? I don't know how to say it, let me see. Yeah, take your time. Stop it, stop it. No, it's okay, just take your time, I'm not gonna. I'm gonna have to think about this one a little bit. Because it's a little bit serious, you know?
但如何正确使用它，她却很难用言语表达清楚。它应该怎么用？我不知道怎么说，让我想想。好的，慢慢来。停下，停下。不，没关系，慢慢来，我不会……我得稍微考虑一下这个问题。因为这有点严肃，你知道吗？
So I have to think in something that I should say. If I were to ask you to draw the Vietnamese flag, and that's all I specified, which one would you draw? That's a good one. I don't know if I can do that. I mean, I guess, you know, like any academic, right? I would say, like, give me more information. This is Thuan Hoang. He's a historian and associate professor at Pepperdine University, who did
所以我得想点应该说的话。如果我让你画越南国旗，而且我只作了这一点要求，你会画哪一面？这是一个好问题。我不知道我能不能做到。我的意思是，我想，你知道的，就像任何学者一样，对吧？我会说，呃，给我更多信息。这是段黄（Thuan Hoang）。他是佩珀代因大学（Pepperdine University）的历史学家兼副教授，他可没有
not fall for my gotcha journalism. A lot like myself, he didn't think to explore the history of the flag until fairly recently. I mean, I did not plan at all to look into the history of the South Vietnamese flag. And then January 6 happened and then boom, it's just like, oh my God, I need to look into this. There were actually several confounding international flags present at the Capitol riot that day. The Canadian, Indian, and South Korean flags were all spotted somewhere in the mayhem. But what was peculiar about the Vietnamese flag being there is that it's not technically
掉进我这种“设套采访”的陷阱里。和我差不多，直到不久前他才开始探索这面旗帜的历史。我的意思是，我根本没打算去研究南越国旗的历史。然后1月6日发生了，接着“轰”的一声，就好像是，天哪，我得研究一下这个。那天在国会山骚乱现场，其实出现了好几面令人眼花缭乱的国际旗帜。在混乱的各处都能看到加拿大、印度和韩国国旗的身影。但越南国旗出现在那里的奇特之处在于，严格来说它并不是
the flag of Vietnam. It's the flag of the Republic of Vietnam, a country that no longer exists. The Republic of Vietnam, or more commonly known as South Vietnam, was in a way a reaction to a reaction to colonialism. Because the country has spent over a thousand years being ruled by outside forces. Colonialism, you know, was massively important in the history of Vietnam. Vietnam spent much of its early history ruled by China. And then in the mid-1800s, Vietnam came under the control of outside powers again, this time France.
越南的国旗。它是越南共和国的国旗，这是一个已经不复存在的国家。越南共和国，或者更广为人知的名字是南越，在某种程度上是对殖民主义反抗的一种反抗。因为这个国家曾花了一千多年的时间受外部势力的统治。殖民主义，你知道的，在越南历史上具有极其重要的意义。越南早期历史的大部分时间都是由中国统治的。然后在19世纪中期，越南再次受到外部列强的控制，这次是法国。
We spent a lot of time dragging British colonialism on the show, but today we're coming for the French. For decades, France exploited Vietnam's natural resources, made the poor more poor, and suppressed Vietnamese identity, even banning the word Vietnam from the region because it was associated with self-determination. The Vietnamese, they hated it. They did not want to be ruled by the French in this case. Another big consequence of colonialism was that it led different Vietnamese people into two clashing political ideologies.
我们在节目里花了很多时间痛斥英国殖民主义，但今天我们要对付法国了。几十年来，法国一直在掠夺越南的自然资源，让穷人愈发贫困，并压制越南人的身份认同，甚至在当地禁止使用“越南”这个词，因为它与自决权联系在一起。越南人，他们对此恨之入骨。在这种情况下，他们不想被法国人统治。殖民主义的另一个重大后果是，它导致不同的越南人走向了两种冲突的政治意识形态。
Some groups were leaning towards reform. Some groups were leaning towards more radical ideology like communism. There were those who believed that yes, colonialism is bad, but also wanted to stay closely aligned with the United States. But leaders like Ho Chi Minh in the North believed that there would be no flourishing under any form of imperialism. Vietnam needed to be a completely independent and communist state. Ho Chi Minh and his army, the Viet Minh,
一些群体倾向于改良。一些群体倾向于更激进的意识形态，比如共产主义。还有一些人认为，是的，殖民主义是不好的，但同时也希望与美国保持紧密的结盟。但像北方的胡志明这样的领导人则认为，在任何形式的帝国主义下都不会有繁荣。越南必须是一个完全独立且共产主义的国家。胡志明和他的军队——越盟（Viet Minh），
defeated the French in 1954, which rattled the Western world. Countries like the US were concerned that communism would continue spreading throughout Southeast Asia. The Palais de Nation, where the League of Nations wrestled with international problems many years ago now, is the handsome setting for the Geneva Conference.
于1954年击败了法国，这让西方世界震惊不已。像美国这样的国家担心共产主义会继续在整个东南亚蔓延。国民宫（Palais de Nation），国际联盟多年前曾在这里艰难处理国际问题，如今成为了日内瓦会议的绝佳会场。
Korea and Indochina are the chief problems to be solved. During the 1954 Geneva Conference, it was decided that France would withdraw from Northern Vietnam. It was also decided that until free elections could be held, the country would be split in two. Vietnam was partitioned at the 17th parallel, with a communist country in the north and in the south,
朝鲜和印度支那（Indochina）是需要解决的核心问题。在1954年的日内瓦会议期间，决定法国将从越南北部撤出。同时决定，在举行自由选举之前，该国将被一分为二。越南在北纬17度线被分割，北方是一个共产主义国家，而南方则是
a country that was nominally democratic with a heavy US influence. Two separate ideologies, territories, and flags. The flag of South Vietnam was a yellow field with three thin red stripes running horizontally across the center. The yellow symbolized the people, and the three red stripes represented the three distinct regions of the country. North, central, and South Vietnam
一个名义上民主、受到美国巨大影响的国家。两种截然不同的意识形态、领土和国旗。南越国旗是一片黄色的底色，中间横贯着三道细红条纹。黄色象征着人民，三条红条纹代表了该国的三个不同地区。北部、中部和南部越南
unified under one banner. In the north, leadership wanted the same thing, a unified Vietnam under these same two colors. But theirs was a different flag, a red field with a bright yellow star at the center. The five points of the star were to represent peasants, workers, intellectuals, traders, and soldiers who unite to build socialism. These two Vietnams clashed in a civil war that lasted for two decades.
统一在同一面旗帜下。在北方，领导层想要的是同样的东西——在同样的这两种颜色下实现越南统一。但他们的国旗不同，是一面红色的底色，正中央有一颗明亮的黄色五角星。五角星的五个角代表着联合起来建设社会主义的农民、工人、知识分子、商人和士兵。这两个越南在一场长达二十年的内战中激烈冲突。
The U.S. wanted South Vietnam to be its anti-communist stronghold in Southeast Asia. But as the war dragged on, it became clearer and clearer that a democratic Vietnam was not possible. And so long story short, right, by 1973, the U.S. troops have withdrawn pretty much completely. They just, you know, don't want to deal with that war anymore. Here's my mom again. She actually lived in Saigon and was in law school during this time. They decide, you know, like, withdraw from the country and then, you know, we know that
美国希望南越成为其在东南亚的反共据点。但随着战争的拖延，越来越明显的是，一个民主的越南是不可能的。长话短说，到1973年，美军几乎完全撤出了。他们只是，你知道的，不想再应付那场战争了。这是我妈妈。她实际上在西贡生活过，这段时间正在读法学院。他们决定，你知道的，从这个国家撤军，然后，你知道的，我们知道
we will, you know, lose the fight with communists. If South Vietnam fell, anyone associated with the U.S. government or South Vietnamese military could be a target for the North Vietnamese regime. My mom had family in the military and also a sister who worked for the Americans, so it wouldn't be safe to stay. But because of these connections, she was able to flee right before the city was captured. We just packed up some little thing, you know, personal thing and go. And I remember I only carry small stuff like personal,
我们会，你知道的，在与共产主义者的战斗中失败。如果南越沦陷，任何与美国政府或南越军方有联系的人都可能成为北越政权的目标。我妈妈的家人在军队里，还有一个姐姐为美国人工作，所以留下来并不安全。但由于这些联系，她在城市被攻占前夕得以逃离。我们只是收拾了一些小东西，你知道的，个人的东西就走了。我记得我只带了很小的主意，比如个人的东西，
like a love letter, a memory book from high school and field clothes, and that's it. Just the backpack, you know, nothing else. My mom was a lot more privileged and a hell of a lot luckier than most people in South Vietnam. And she still lost everything. Oh, I'm crying.
像情书、高中纪念册和便服，就这样。只有一个背包，别的什么都没有。我妈妈比南越大多数人享有更多的特权，也幸运得多。但她还是失去了一切。哦，我在哭。
When the flight left off, and I see the land down there, and my tears just come out a lot. I know that I never see it again. She was actually on one of the last planes to leave the country. The next day, the airport was bombed. A few days later, North Vietnamese tanks crashed through the gates of the presidential palace in Saigon and took down the flag of South Vietnam. The war was over.
当飞机起飞，我看到底下的土地时，我的眼泪就止不住地流出来。我知道我再也见不到它了。她其实是最后一批离开该国的飞机之一。第二天，机场就被轰炸了。几天后，北越的坦克冲破了西贡总统府的大门，降下了南越国旗。战争结束了。
The conquering tanks burst straight into the presidential palace. For the fourth time in a month, the presidential palace had new occupants, but these had come to stay. ["Mong Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Long Vietnamese. This is Thuy Vo Dang, curator of UC Irvine's Southeast Asian Archive. In Vietnam, it's known as Liberation Day. And in the diaspora, it's often referred to as Ngay Muk Nga, or the day we lost our homeland, right, or Ngay Gwak Hung, or the day of national resentment. After the fall of Saigon, the North and South once again became one nation. The new government of the Socialist Republic of Vietnam
征服的坦克直接冲进了总统府。在一个月内第四次，总统府迎来了新的主人，但这些人是来长久驻留的。越南人。这是翠·武当（Thuy Vo Dang），加州大学欧文分校（UC Irvine）东南亚档案馆的馆长。在越南，它被称为“解放日”（Liberation Day）。而在海外侨民中，它通常被称为“Ngay Muk Nga”（失去祖国的日子，对吧），或者“Ngay Gwak Hung”（民族怨恨之日）。西贡陷落后，南北方再次成为一个国家。越南社会主义共和国的新政府
immediately went to task undoing years of capitalist influence on the southern half of the country. And so they embark on a number of measures, you know, that affected all of Vietnam, but especially South Vietnamese, right? This vision of establishing a socialist paradise, so to speak. This included changing the currency of Vietnam
立即着手消除多年来资本主义对该国南部的影响。因此，他们着手采取了一系列措施，你知道的，这些措施影响了整个越南，但尤其是南越人，对吧。可以这么说，这种建立社会主义天堂的愿景。这包括更改越南的货币
to undercut the wealthy elites and forcibly relocating roughly a million southerners. But the most infamous post-war policy was incarcerating former South Vietnamese military officers, religious leaders, journalists, academics, artists, basically anyone who didn't agree with the North Vietnamese government in re-education camps, where they spent years starving and forced into manual labor. After the country reunified, South Vietnam didn't just lose its political recognition
以削弱富裕精英阶层，并强行重新安置大约一百万南方人。但战后最臭名昭著的政策是将前南越军官、宗教领袖、记者、学者、艺术家——基本上所有不同意北越政府的人——关押在再教育营里，他们在那里度过了多年的饥饿生活，并被迫进行体力劳动。国家重新统一后，南越不仅失去了其政治承认
and its spot on the map. It was actively erased. The government confiscated records, cassette tapes, right, of music produced in South Vietnam. They confiscated hundreds of thousands of books and magazines that were published in South Vietnam. And many of them were burned. So when the first wave of South Vietnamese refugees settled in other parts of the world in the late 70s and early 80s,
及其在地图上的位置。它被积极地抹去了。政府没收了在南越制作的音乐的记录、磁带，对吧。他们没收了在南越出版的数十万本书籍和杂志。其中许多都被烧毁了。因此，当第一波南越难民在70年代末和80年代初定居世界其他地方时，
that music, history, and culture became the responsibility of the diaspora. Which is why the flag is so important to people like my mom. We cherish that flag since the day that we fled the country and we don't have the land anymore. We just, you know, have the flag. Tuan Hoang says that for a lot of early Vietnamese American refugees, the yellow flag with red stripes stands for more than an allegiance to a non-existent country. It also represents a different, less commonly told perspective on the Vietnam War. There are enough history books and documentaries on the subject to keep any retired dead occupied for years.
这些音乐、历史和文化就变成了海外侨民的责任。这就是为什么这面旗帜对像我妈妈这样的人来说如此重要。自从我们逃离这个国家、我们不再拥有这片土地的那一天起，我们就一直珍视这面旗帜。我们只是，你知道的，拥有这面旗帜。段黄说，对于许多早期的越南裔美国难民来说，带有红色条纹的黄旗不仅仅代表着对一个不存在的国家的忠诚。它还代表了关于越战的一种不同的、较少被讲述的视角。关于这个主题的历史纪录片和书籍多得足以让任何退休的老人忙上好几年。
But these were all about America's role in the war, America's mistakes, America's loss. Even the most visible monument to the war, the Vietnam Veterans Memorial in D.C., was a tribute to the U.S. service members. But really, really, really, there was hardly anything that represents the South Vietnamese experience. The South Vietnamese flag did that. For the generation that fled the country, it became a banner, a memorial, and a link connecting the South Vietnamese scattered all around the world. As the U.S. rekindled diplomatic relations with Vietnam in the late 80s and 90s, a new wave of migration took place to the West. Many of those South Vietnamese had been political prisoners
但这些全都是关于美国在战争中的角色、美国的错误、美国的失败。甚至连战争中最显眼的纪念碑——华盛顿特区的越战退伍军人纪念碑，也是对美国军人的致敬。但真的、真的、真的，几乎没有什么东西能代表南越人的经历。南越国旗做到了这一点。对于逃离该国的那一代人来说，它成为了一面横幅、一座纪念碑，以及连接散落在世界各地的南越人的纽带。随着美国在80年代末和90年代重新与越南建立外交关系，新一波的移民潮涌向了西方。许多南越人曾是政治犯
after the fall of Saigon. So to them, seeing this flag flying broad took on new meaning that wasn't just about nostalgia. The experience of Vietnamese, right, who were living difficult lives in Vietnam after the war, and who eventually came to the US, I mean, you know, Canada, so on, right? They experience it as a symbol of freedom,
在西贡陷落之后。因此对他们来说，看到这面旗帜广泛飘扬被赋予了新的意义，这不仅仅是关于怀旧。越南人的经历，对吧，他们在战后在越南过着艰难的生活，并最终来到美国、加拿大的这些人，对吧？他们将其体验为一种自由的象征，
you know, post-war freedom. Municipalities all over the world actually fly the South Vietnamese flag out of respect for local Vietnamese communities. And it has been reclassified as the freedom and heritage flag in a number of cities across the country. If you spent enough time in a Vietnamese enclave, you might end up thinking that this was the
你知道的，战后的自由。世界各地的城市为了表达对当地越南社群的尊重，实际上都在悬挂南越国旗。它在全国许多城市已被重新归类为“自由与遗产旗”（freedom and heritage flag）。如果你在越南人聚居区花足够长的时间，你最终可能会认为这就是
official flag of Vietnam. I 100% grew up thinking that. I actually remember the day that I found out Vietnam's official flag was something different. I was in sixth grade and our social studies class was assigned a project. It was something that you've probably had to do at some point in grade school. It was a country report. You choose a nation and then compile a bunch of data, tuck it into a neat little binder, and then present it to the rest of your class. Being Vietnamese-American and also wanting to put in as little effort as possible, I naturally chose Vietnam. But part of the assignment was to draw a picture of that nation's flag, so I booted up in
越南的官方国旗。我100%是带着这种想法长大的。我还记得我发现越南的官方国旗是另一种东西的那一天。当时我在读六年级，我们的社会科老师布置了一个项目。这是你在小学时可能在某个时候都做过的事情。那是一份国家报告。你选择一个国家，然后收集一堆数据，把它塞进一个整洁的小夹子里，然后向全班其他同学展示。作为一名越南裔美国人，同时也想尽可能少花力气，我自然选择了越南。但作业的一部分是画出那个国家的国旗，所以我启动了
Carta 95, a program that I was using well into the year 2001, and used some colored pencils to transpose the graphic that I saw onto a sheet of paper. It was a red field, with a bright yellow five-pointed star at the center. I didn't recognize this flag, but who was I to question in Carta 95? The morning my project was due, my dad was horrified at the sight of that five-pointed star on my homework. And that reaction is pretty common among South Vietnamese refugees. You would not want to show that flag.
网景浏览器（Carta 95，注：应为Netscape Navigator，此处为播客口误或机翻误听，译文按原意处理），这个我一直用到2001年的程序，然后用彩色铅笔把我看到的图形转描到一张纸上。那是一片红色的底色，正中央有一颗明亮的黄色五角星。我不认识这面旗帜，但我又怎么能质疑网景浏览器（Carta 95）呢？交作业的那个早晨，我爸爸看到我作业上的那颗五角星时吓坏了。这种反应在南越难民中非常普遍。你绝对不想展示那面旗帜。
Yeah, people would really throw things at you. A lot of refugees see the official flag, the red flag with the yellow five-pointed star, as a reminder of what they'd fled in Vietnam. So as Vietnamese Americans became more politically active in the 90s and early 2000s, essentially anywhere the official flag appeared, a protest would follow. They were a constant thing every weekend, you know, in Little Saigon there was a protest that was somehow related to the flag. The biggest incident happened in 1999 at a suburban strip mall right at the heart of Orange County's Little Saigon. Actually, just two blocks from where my parents worked.
是的，人们真的会向你扔东西。许多难民将官方国旗——带有黄色五角星的红旗——视为他们在越南逃离过的事物的提醒。因此，随着越南裔美国人在90年代和2000年代初变得更加积极参与政治，基本上只要官方国旗出现的地方，抗议活动就会随之而来。它们每个周末都在持续发生，你知道的，在小西贡（Little Saigon），总会有某种与国旗相关的抗议活动。最大的事件发生在1999年，地点在奥兰治县小西贡心脏地带的一个郊区购物中心。实际上，离我父母工作的地方只有两个街区。
The scene was reminiscent of the 60s, row after row of police in full riot gear. Civil disobedience. The owner of a video store called Hi Tech TV and VCR was a recent immigrant from Vietnam, and he decided to put up the red flag along with a portrait of Ho Chi Minh. The owner in this case was kind of asking for trouble. Well, he was literally asking for trouble. The store owner actually sent fax messages to local Vietnamese community leaders detailing what he had done and daring them to do something about it.
这个场景让人想起60年代，一排又一排全副武装的警察。公民抗命。一家名为“高科技电视与录像机”（Hi Tech TV and VCR）的音像店老板是来自越南的新移民，他决定挂起红旗以及胡志明的肖像。这位店老板在这种情况下简直是自找麻烦。好吧，他字面意义上就是在自找麻烦。这位店老板甚至向当地越南社群领袖发送了传真，详细说明了他所做的事情，并挑衅他们采取行动。
The protest lasted for months, and at its peak, the LA Times recorded over 15,000 protesters in one day. I used to get my hair cut in this plaza, and I cannot imagine that many people cramming into that little parking lot. Tui Vo Deng actually went to these protests back in 1999, and could see that, yes, the official red star flag was capable of setting off a firestorm of controversy. But the yellow flag of South Vietnam could also be a polarizing symbol, especially when you think about who is excluded and what kind of conversations are shut down by it.
抗议活动持续了几个月，《洛杉矶时报》记录到，在最高峰时，一天内有超过1.5万名抗议者。我以前在这个广场剪头发，我无法想象那么多人能挤进那个小停车场。翠·武当确实在1999年参加了这些抗议活动，并且能够看到，是的，官方的红星旗确实能够引发一场充满争议的风暴。但南越的黄旗也可能是一个极具两极分化的象征，特别是当你考虑到谁被排除了、什么样的对话被它所扼杀时。
It is the only flag allowed in Little Saigon. So that is a certain kind of sanctioning as well, right? And how do people who have immigrated here very recently have grown up in Vietnam with the red flag only? How do they feel around the Lunar New Year when they walk around Bolsa Avenue and only see the yellow flag? The South Vietnamese flag could be especially inciting when used in community politics. If the official five-pointed star flag of Vietnam is viewed as the communist flag, then the yellow flag with red stripes of South Vietnam is seen as the anti-communist flag.
它是小西贡唯一被允许悬挂的国旗。所以这也是一种特定类型的认可，对吧？那些最近才移民到这里、在越南只伴随着红旗长大的人，他们作何感想？当他们在农历新年期间走在博尔萨大道（Bolsa Avenue）上却只看到黄旗时，他们是什么感觉？南越国旗在用于社群政治时尤其具有煽动性。如果越南官方的五角星旗被视为共产主义国旗，那么南越带有红色条纹的黄旗就被视为反共国旗。
When you call someone a communist in the little Saigon community, that's like a death knell for their political career. Right, it's slanderous, it's like... So, I mean, I've seen it used in ways that have been intended to cause harm, right, to leverage the emotional weight that we've put to this flag, right, and try to hurt others. These staunch anti-communist views are actually a big part of why first-generation Vietnamese
当你在小西贡社群里称呼某人为共产党人时，这就如同给他们的政治生涯敲响了丧钟。没错，这是诽谤，这就像是……所以，我的意思是，我见过它被用于旨在造成伤害的方式，对吧，利用我们对这面旗帜赋予的情感分量，对吧，试图去伤害他人。这些坚定的反共观点实际上是第一代越南裔
Americans have always been a pretty reliable Republican voting bloc. That and a lot of Vietnamese people also tend to be drawn to the GOP's hardline stance on China, which I don't agree with. But apparently a thousand years of occupation and territorial disputes can lead to a pretty gnarly grudge. That is something that we can actually generalize meaningfully. The easiest way to anger a Vietnamese is just say something nice about China. The South Vietnamese flag has been drifting towards politically conservative symbolism for a while now. For some, the yellow flag with red stripes has become a shorthand for right-wing nationalism. It had been a constant presence at Trump rallies leading up to January 6th,
美国人一直是一个相当可靠的共和党投票集团的重要原因。再加上许多越南人也往往会被GOP（共和党）对中国的强硬立场吸引，虽然我并不同意这一点。但显然，一千年的占领和领土争端可以导致相当深重的怨恨。这是我们可以进行有意义的概括的一点。激怒一个越南人的最简单方法就是说一些赞美中国的好话。南越国旗一段时间以来一直在向政治保守主义象征意义漂移。对有些人来说，带有红色条纹的黄旗已经成为右翼民族主义的代名词。在通往1月6日的特朗普集会上，它一直是常客，
so many of us in the community weren't even surprised to see it at the insurrection. — At least half a dozen protesters scaling. — I was disheartened. I was, you know, I was angry. I was frustrated, all of those things, but I wasn't surprised. — There's a huge generational divide in the Vietnamese community when it comes to politics. So much so that there's even a support group on Facebook for Asian Americans with Republican parents that's filled with second-generation Vietnamese kids.
因此我们社群中的许多人甚至对在叛乱中看到它并不感到惊讶。“——至少有六名抗议者在攀爬。”——我感到沮丧。我，你知道的，我很生气。我很懊恼，所有这些情绪都有，但我并不感到惊讶。“——越南社群在政治方面存在着巨大的代沟。”以至于甚至在Facebook上有一个专为拥有共和党父母的亚裔美国人设立的支持小组，里面充满了第二代越南年轻人。
Like a lot of conservative America, Republican Vietnamese have been drawn to Trumpism. And for the older generation especially, the ones who experienced the war, there could still be a deep fear of communism. So when they hear stuff like this, Like it or not, we are becoming a communist country. That's what's happening. that pulls on actual lived trauma. The people who brought the South Vietnamese flag to the insurrection only represented
就像许多保守派美国人一样，共和党越南人也被特朗普主义所吸引。尤其是对于老一辈人，那些经历过战争的人来说，内心可能仍然存在对共产主义的深深恐惧。所以当他们听到这样的话时，不管你喜不喜欢，我们正在变成一个共产主义国家。事情就是这样。那会触及实际的生活创伤。把南越国旗带到叛乱现场的人只代表了
a very small and very noisy subsect of the community. Most people, including my mom, hated seeing the flag there that day. That day, that January 6th, right? There's a lot of debate after that in the community. There's a lot of people against that people bring the flag to that event, you know? And me too, I don't like it. In the days following January 6th, a number of write-ups were published to help people, quote, decode some of the racist imagery of the insurrection.
社群中一个非常小且非常喧闹的细分群体。大多数人，包括我妈妈，都不愿意在那天看到这面旗帜出现在那里。那天，那个1月6日，对吧？在那之后社群里有很多争论。有很多人反对人们把国旗带到那个活动中，你知道的？我也是，我也不喜欢它。在1月6日之后的几天里，发表了许多文章来帮助人们“引号”解码叛乱的一些种族主义意象。
And some of them included the South Vietnamese flag. I felt queasy seeing it lumped in with all these symbols of hate. For a large swath of the US, January 6th was probably the first time they had even seen the South Vietnamese flag. It is not far-fetched to think that some observers may have wondered what radical group this yellow flag with red stripes represented.
其中一些文章甚至包含了南越国旗。看到它与所有这些仇恨象征混为一谈，我感到一阵恶心。对于美国很大一部分人来说，1月6日可能是他们第一次见到南越国旗。认为某些观察家可能会想知道这面带有红色条纹的黄旗代表了哪个激进组织，这种想法并非天方夜谭。
The South Vietnamese flag's presence that day brought up a lot of questions for those of us who don't want to see it end up like Pepe the Frog. But Thuy Vo Dang thinks that this doesn't just have to be an embarrassing moment for the Vietnamese American community. It could also be an opportunity to face our history before it gets co-opted by any side of the political spectrum. It's up to us to do the work of pushing the conversation towards understanding the nuances and complexities of our history.
南越国旗那天出现在那里，为我们这些不希望它最终变成“佩佩蛙”（Pepe the Frog）一样的人提出了很多问题。但翠·武当认为，这不一定只是美籍越南人社群的一个尴尬时刻。这也可能是一个面对我们历史的机会，在它被政治谱系的任何一方劫持之前。我们有责任努力将对话推向理解我们历史的细微差别和复杂性。
But I think, you know, all of the attention that came after the appearance of the yellow flag at the insurrection could enable an entry point. I think a lot of people in my generation have a very different relationship to this flag and to Vietnam itself. To me, the flag just can't be boiled down to freedom or nostalgia or anti-communism or any of the other one-liners ascribed to it. It's a complex symbol for the complicated history of how I got here. When I just start up my life here, I miss everything in the past, but now it's okay. I like it here.
但我认为，你知道的，黄旗在叛乱中出现后引起的所有关注可以提供一个切入点。我认为我这一代人中的许多人与这面旗帜以及越南本身有着非常不同的关系。对我来说，这面旗帜不能简单地归结为自由、怀旧、反共或任何赋予它的其他顺口溜。对于我如何来到这里的复杂历史来说，它是一个复杂的象征。当我刚在这里开始生活时，我怀念过去的一切，但现在没关系了。我喜欢这里。
I hadn't really thought about it before, but my mom's life directly reflects the yellow flag with red stripes. She was born in 1955, the same year that South Vietnam was created, and she fled the country in 1975, the year it ended. — I just spent 20 years of my life, first life in Vietnam. And now I'm 66, so more than the book here in the United States. So I love this country. — My mom said something that stuck with me
我以前没有真正想过这一点，但我妈妈的生活直接映射了带有红色条纹的黄旗。她出生于1955年，也就是南越建立的那一年；她于1975年逃离该国，也就是它结束的那一年。“——我刚刚度过了我生命的20年，在越南的第一段生活。现在我66岁了，所以在美国的岁月比在书里的还要长。所以我爱这个国家。”——我妈妈说的一句话深深触动了我
that I think applies to the flag of South Vietnam too. She doesn't want to live in the past, but she doesn't want to forget it either. She wants the same for me too. Because one day, the war will stop being a living memory and just be history. And what we'll be left with is a yellow flag with red stripes. After the break, Vivian comes back to help decode the hidden history behind Vietnamese restaurant names.
我认为这也适用于南越国旗。她不想活在过去，但她也不想忘记过去。她也希望我能如此。因为总有一天，战争将不再是一个活生生的记忆，而仅仅成为历史。而我们留下的，将是一面带有红色条纹的黄旗。休息过后，薇薇安将回来帮助解码越南餐厅名称背后的隐藏历史。
So we're back with Vivien Lai. Thank you so much for that story. I always love the stories where I learn a little bit more about you guys' lives. Yeah, and talk to our parents too. Exactly. So yeah, so this is actually going to be like the Vietnamese-iest episode ever because I'm going to talk about pho restaurants. So if any listeners don't know what pho is, I feel bad for you because it's so good. It's probably the most visible dish that has come out of Vietnam.
欢迎回来，我们和薇薇安·赖（Vivien Lai）在一起。非常感谢你带来的这个故事。我总是很喜欢那些能让我多了解一点你们生活的日子的故事。是的，也和我们的父母聊聊。没错。所以，是的，这实际上将是有史以来最“越南”的一集，因为我要谈论河粉（pho）餐厅。因此，如果任何听众不知道什么是pho，我为你感到难过，因为它太棒了。这可能是从越南走出来的最显眼的菜肴。
Like when I meet someone and they find out I'm Vietnamese and they don't know how to make conversation a lot of times they'll be like, well, I like pho. I'm like, okay, great. Thank you for that. But like, I guess to boil it down to its most basic level, it's like a noodle plus protein plus fragrant broth soup. And it has like bean sprouts and Thai basil and lime and onions.
就像当我遇到某人，他们发现我是越南人，而他们不知道该怎么聊天时，很多时候他们会说，嗯，我喜欢pho。我说，好的，太棒了。谢谢你这么说。但是，我想，如果把它归结为最基本的层面，它就像是面条加上蛋白质再加上香气扑鼻的高汤。里面还有豆芽、泰国罗勒、青柠和洋葱。
Yeah, you're given a kit when you get it. It's like, it is really the greatest soup. And I know that that's a contentious subject when it comes to a lot of people and a lot of soups in different cultures, but I'm here to tell you, Pho is the best. Oh, it's the best soup. Yeah, the accoutrements alone that come with the bowl of Pho. But you know, if you drive through pretty much any little Saigon in the world,
是的，你拿到它的时候会附带一套配料。就像是，它真的是最棒的汤。我知道当涉及到很多人和不同文化中的许多汤时，这是一个有争议的话题，但我要在这里告诉你，pho就是最好的。哦，它是最棒的汤。是的，单单是那一碗pho附带的佐料就够了。但你知道，如果你开车穿过世界上差不多任何一个小西贡，
you would probably notice that there's this really common naming convention when it comes to Pho restaurants. And I think it's really well articulated by Ali Wong in her comedy special, Baby Cobra. So Wong herself is Vietnamese and there's this part where she's talking about how her now husband tried to take her to like a quote authentic Vietnamese restaurant on one of their first dates. He took me to this restaurant on the west side of Los Angeles called Pho Sho. called Faux Show. He was like, it's authentic Vietnamese. I read about it on Yelp.
你可能会注意到河粉餐厅有一个非常普遍的命名惯例。我想黄阿丽（Ali Wong）在她的喜剧特辑《眼镜蛇宝宝》（Baby Cobra）中对此做了非常精彩的阐述。所以黄阿丽本人是越南人，其中有一段她在讲述她现在的丈夫如何在他们的第一次约会之一时试图带她去一家所谓的“正宗越南餐厅”。他带我去了洛杉矶西区的一家餐厅，叫做Pho Sho（河粉秀）。叫做Pho Sho。他说，这是正宗的越南菜。我在Yelp上读到过。
I was like, it's not authentic. Okay, you can tell first and foremost by the name because it don't got a number in it. So she's talking about this completely valid stereotype about Vietnamese restaurants that they're always named like the word pho plus a seemingly random number. Like right now I'm looking at a map of Orange County and there's a pho 99 right next to a pho 86, which is less than a block away from a pho 45. And then there's a pho 54 around the corner from a pho 79, which is less than a block away from a Pho 45. And then there's a Pho 54 around the corner from a Pho 79, which is very good, by the
我说，这不正宗。好吧，你首先可以通过名字看出来，因为它里面没有数字。所以她谈到了关于越南餐厅的一个完全成立的刻板印象，即它们的命名总是类似于“pho”这个词加上一个看似随機的数字。就像现在我正在看一张奥兰治县的地图，在pho 86旁边就有一个pho 99，它距离pho 45不到一个街区。然后，在pho 79的拐角处还有一个pho 54，它距离pho 45不到一个街区。然后，在pho 79的拐角处还有一个pho 54，顺便说一句，这家非常不错。
way. It's a great restaurant. So there's a very, very common thing that you will see with Vietnamese restaurants that they always kind of include a number. So what's the number all about? Yeah. So sometimes the restaurant will have a number just because like the numbers themselves are lucky.
这是个很棒的餐厅。所以你会看到越南餐厅有一个非常非常普遍的现象，那就是它们总是会包含一个数字。那么这个数字到底是怎么回事呢？是的。所以有时餐厅会有数字，纯粹是因为数字本身很幸运。
Like if you see a Pho 555 or a Pho 888, it's because five and eight are auspicious numbers in a lot of Eastern cultures. Plus, it's super memorable to have three numbers in a row. But if you pay close enough attention to the numbers, they can actually tell you about the restaurant's owner's family history or the history of Vietnam in general. So if you see a restaurant called like Pho 86 or Pho 79, that could represent that the owner of the restaurant immigrated from Vietnam in 1986 or in 1979. So that's a really common naming convention in Vietnamese American culture. And it's this way to kind of pay tribute to the start of this new life.
比如你看到Pho 555或Pho 888，那是因为在许多东方文化中，五和八是吉祥的数字。另外，连续三个数字让人超级难忘。但如果你足够关注这些数字，它们实际上可以告诉你餐厅老板的家庭历史或越南的总体历史。所以如果你看到一家名为Pho 86或Pho 79的餐厅，这可能代表着该餐厅的老板于1986年或1979年从越南移民。所以这是越南裔美国文化中一个非常普遍的命名惯例。这是一种向这段新生活的起点致敬的方式。
Yeah, like around our office in Oakland, we have a FAH 84, which I like to visit. So my guess is 84 makes it one of those ones where it's indicative of a year. Yeah, exactly. Like usually the numbers are signifying some sort of year. So you'll also see a lot of places named like FAH 75 specifically. Right. And 75 is a really important number in Vietnamese American culture because 1975 is the year of the fall of Saigon and the end of South Vietnam.
是的，就像我们在奥克兰的办公室周围，有一家FAH 84，我很喜欢去光顾。所以我猜84使其成为了那些表明年份的其中一家。是的，完全正确。通常这些数字都在某种程度上象征着年份。所以你也会看到很多店专门命名为FAH 75。没错。75在越南裔美国文化中是一个非常重要的数字，因为1975年是西贡陷落和南越灭亡的年份。
So a lot of Vietnamese Americans actually commemorate it every year with something called Black April, which marks the day that Saigon fell on April 30th, 1975. Wow. I've never heard of Black April. That's really fascinating. Yeah. It's celebrated mostly in like little Saigon's and stuff. So yeah, it was a big thing where I was growing up.
因此，许多美籍越南人实际上每年都会用一种叫做“黑色四月”（Black April）的活动来纪念它，这标志着西贡于1975年4月30日陷落的日子。哇。我从来没听说过“黑色四月”。这真的很迷人。是的。它主要是在小西贡之类的地方庆祝。所以，是的，在我成长的过程中，这是一件大事。
So you might see a lot of FUH 75s because there was a lot of immigration activity in 1975 because of the fall of Saigon. Yeah, exactly. So another restaurant number you'll probably see a lot is FUH 54. Yeah. So we talk about this, we talk about 54 in the piece. This is when the creation of South Vietnam, the partitioning of the country. Yeah, exactly. So this is when Vietnam was split basically into North and South Vietnam.
所以你可能会看到很多FAH 75，因为由于西贡的陷落，1975年有大量的移民活动。是的，完全正确。所以你可能会经常看到的另一个餐厅数字是FAH 54。是的。所以我们谈到了这个，我们在节目中谈到了54。这是南越的建立，国家的分割。是的，完全正确。所以这就是越南基本上被分裂为南北越的时候。
And this is actually a really big date in Vietnamese food culture as well, because when the country was split in two, there was this huge migration of people between North and South Vietnam, because the North was now communist country, the South was now anti-communist. So in the US, they called this operation Passage to Freedom, but essentially it was this grace
而且这也是越南饮食文化中一个非常重要的日期，因为当国家一分为二时，越南南北方之间发生了大规模的人口迁移，因为当时北方成为了共产主义国家，南方则是反共的。因此在美方，他们称这次行动为“自由通行”，但本质上这是一个缓冲
period where people were allowed to flee the North or the South before the border was officially sealed. So somewhere between 600,000 to a million North Vietnamese actually relocated to the South. And this is actually how my mom's family ended up in Saigon because they were part of this migration from the north to the south. Yeah. But this was important for like Vietnamese food culture specifically too, because pho is a dish that actually originated from North Vietnam. So for a long time, pho wasn't actually something that was eaten very much in South Vietnam. Like, if you've ever been there, it's very, very hot and you steam you there.
期，在边境正式封锁之前，人们被允许逃离北方或南方。因此，大约有60万到100万越南北方人实际上搬到了南方。这也是我妈妈的家人最终来到西贡的原因，因为他们是这次从北到南迁移的一部分。是的。但这对于越南饮食文化本身也很重要，因为河粉这道菜实际上源自越南北部。所以在很长一段时间里，河粉在越南南部其实并不是经常被食用的东西。比如说，如果你去过那里，那里非常非常热，你在那里会直冒热气。
But it became really popular in the South because this huge influx of Northerners that relocated to places like Saigon. And pho itself changed a lot after it was brought to South Vietnam because of the available ingredients like in South Vietnam. So originally it was pretty simple, but that's when we started putting like the herbs and the bean sprouts and just packing it with all this stuff. And so this kind of hybrid north-south version of pho is what was taken abroad when Vietnamese started immigrating to other parts of the world after the war. Oh, that's cool.
但它在南方变得非常受欢迎，因为大量北方人搬到了西贡等地。而且河粉在被带到越南南部之后发生了很大变化，因为南方的食材有所不同。所以最初它很简单，但也就是从那时起，我们开始加入香草、豆芽，并在里面塞满了各种东西。因此，这种南北结合的河粉版本就是后来战争结束后越南人向世界其他地区移民时带到国外的版本。哦，这太酷了。
Yeah, yeah. And so actually this tradition of naming restaurants to include a number in it, like an important date or something, is actually something that you mostly see in the older restaurants, like by people who are the first generation immigrants. So newer Vietnamese restaurants tend to be less likely to adhere to that numbered name convention. So the stereotype about it not being like quote authentic, like a quote authentic Vietnamese restaurant kind of comes from somewhere just because you know the places with the numbers will be more old school, more traditional.
对，对。事实上，餐馆名字中包含一个数字（比如一个重要日期或其他数字）的传统，主要出现在老字号餐馆中，也就是第一代移民经营的餐馆。所以较新的越南餐馆往往不太会遵循这种数字命名的传统。因此，关于它“不够正宗”的刻板印象（比如不像一家正宗的越南餐馆）确实是有一定根据的，因为你知道，名字带数字的地方会更古老、更传统。
Like I personally try to avoid anything with like a pun on the word pho in it. You know like the restaurant pho nominal or something like that for me. Well especially ones that you know imply that pho rhymes with show or that it's pho. Yes. Oh, yeah. That is my biggest pet feed. It's pho. It's not pho.
比如我个人尽量避免任何带有“pho”字双关语的名字。你知道的，比如叫什么 Pho-nomenal 之类的餐馆。特别是那些暗示 pho 和 show 押韵，或者把它读成 pho 的餐馆。是的。哦，是的。这是我最痛恨的事。它是 pho，不是 pho。
Please, please, please no. Take anything from this coda. Pho. Say, do pho your best you can. Just remember pho. Yeah. Well, this is fascinating. I love the idea that you could drive through a neighborhood and just know a family's history
拜托，拜托，千万别这样。从这段音频里学到一点吧。读作 pho。好吧，尽你所能去读 pho 吧。只要记住是 pho。嗯。好吧，这太迷人了。我喜欢这种想法：你只要开车穿过一个街区，就能从河粉店的名字
from the names of the far places. I mean, that's the coolest. Yeah. All right. Well, thank you, Vivian. Yeah, thank you. This episode originally aired in 2021. It was produced by Vivian Le, edited by Christopher Johnson, mixed by Amita Ganatra, with music
中了解到一个家庭的历史。我的意思是，这太酷了。好了。谢谢你，薇薇安。不客气，谢谢你。本期节目最初于2021年播出。由薇薇安·勒制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊编辑，阿米塔·加纳特拉混音，音乐
by Swan Rial. Special thanks to Long T. Bui, Diana Lay, and Grace Lay. Kathy Tu is our Executive Producer, Kurt Kolstad is the Digital Director, Delaney Hall is our Senior Editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Peruve, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzalez, Lasha Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
由斯旺·里亚尔创作。特别感谢龙·T·布伊、黛安娜·莱和格蕾丝·莱。凯茜·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德兰妮·霍尔是高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁韦、杰森·德莱昂、埃met·菲茨杰拉德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、拉沙·马东、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。
We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky, as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Hi, this is Vivian's mom, Stitcher, SiriusXM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城。你可以在 Blue Sky 以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在那里以及 99PI.org 上可以找到指向该服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。嗨，我是薇薇安的妈妈，Stitcher，SiriusXM。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。